Ha ha!
Get baited!
There was no other loop.
It's just me.
We're live.
Hello, everybody.
I wasn't actually prepping for anything.
I just, I don't know.
I was like, what if I just kept looping?
I was actually ready after the first loop.
I was just like, oh, but what if we just kept going?
Let's see how far.
I'll take this.
And I was like, I should actually start stream.
We should get started.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello, everybody.
I am, guys, I'm taking too much work.
I'm like, after, um, it's supposed to be after Vexpo.
I get to chill, but obviously it's not that.
It's not that anymore.
Because after Vexpo, we have the Apex tournament that we're,
uh, we're gonna be doing uh next week and i'm still uh
working on that i'm still prepping for that um because i
remember um i remember with um with my manager um uh he was
like all right can't wait uh can't wait to to relax after
vexpo and then guess what we're gonna be organizing a
tournament The wake never ends.
You're here forever.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll take 10 more loops, Stokie.
Please.
Did someone say another loop?
Hey, guys, I'll do anything for money.
I'm sorry.
Unless somebody pays for him to stop.
I'll see you guys in 10 loops.
The cyclist.
broken and I will divide you there's always one I just
needed to find that one dragon that was gonna break as the
loop kept continuing on and on I saw the cracks in your
little group I saw it history will always repeat itself use
the you're in control I'm the one that's in control you
think you're all about unity and kumbaya how you're all so
strong but that's right I already saw the cracks forming
within your little group you have there you have I am all
the power here.
Hey Jake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A chain is only as strong as it's the weakest link.
It might not have been, it could have been any one of you as
long as the loop kept continuing.
I saw the cracks unfolding more and more.
super chat thank you thank you enjoy your 30 pieces of
silver loops thank you super chat thank you thank you
darling thank you the super chat thank you thank you door
mom will have come to bargain for more loops thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you i was like the snake
tempting you to eat that apple and i knew one of you was
gonna betray them all I knew there was a Judas amongst you.
I knew you would eat the apple.
Next, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So that was your alt account from Kingdom Hearts Day.
Right, shape my head.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Even dad knows how much for more loop.
Seaburg, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
super chat thank you what did the uk do to her she's
becoming a bond villain did she drink from the coolate thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm gonna give
dad the rest of his food so you know what one more for the
ride hello everybody and welcome back to the dokeybird
channel
uh darian thank you for the super chat thank you thing Thank
you.
Alright, today we are gonna be playing, uh, what's the game
called?
Clash Cash Cash Cleaner Simulator.
Uh, what if this was my money laundering scheme?
This is- I got it very inspired, guys.
What if all these super chats was just a giant money
laundering scheme?
I'll never tell.
It's like nothing happened.
And you're watching the Doki Channel.
I will say I do have a dokey Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We got a clean we're cleaning the we're cleaning the super
chat cache right now All right, so Today on the dokey news
network Do you guys hear about the latest Pokemon scalping
news that's going on right now on the dokey news network?
So apparently for the 30th anniversary that all the scalpers
were so hyped about the scalp for the Pokemon 30th
anniversary cards where apparently it was like, you know,
everyone thought it was going to be a huge payday for the
scalpers because it's like I said, it's the 30th
anniversary.
So it's a very special, uh, it's a very special uh set.
And apparently, uh, Pokemon, the Pokemon company pulled a
fast one on the scalpers because they flooded the market.
They fucking flooded the entire market of the 30th
anniversary set.
So, like, a bunch of scalpers spent, like, thousands of
dollars, like, 50-plus grand buying a bunch of these cards.
And now, the market is so...
But then the thing is, the stores instantly restock them
every day because the Pokemon Company flooded the entire
market for specifically for the 30th anniversary so there's
like uh there's like a private scalper discord uh for
pokemon scalpers and everybody is freaking out right now and
uh and like wanting to sue the pokemon company for
destroying the economy destroying the market yeah for
destroying the market and attacking small business owners
Which is fucking crazy.
I was just like...
How fucking oblivious are you?
What's the word?
They have no like...
They have no awareness at all.
Paturus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a small business owner, I have to know the thought going
through your head when you saw those scalpers cry that
Nintendo was attacking small business owners like
themselves.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, there was like...
self-awareness at all for these scalpers let me show you a
screenshot of what they were saying uh so this is from
apparently it's like a private scalping pokemon discord
server and of all scalpers are just crying about it uh it's
like i don't know what to do i maxed out three different
credit cards buying as much 30th anniversary stuff as
possible everyone's talking about it for over a year.
It's the most hype said ever.
Why do they make so much?
What am I going to tell my wife?
There's no way I can offload all this at profit.
And my local stores aren't accepting returns.
I've been nothing but loyal to this brand for over eight
months, by the way.
And this is how they treat us.
They knew it would financially ruin people.
They knew the secondary economy Communist government
controlling their currency Pokemon's greed ruined my lively
The thing is, you're like, there's no way these guys are
laughing, these guys are like fucking around, they're
trolling but then there's like, the thing is there was more,
these were not the only messages they were I have about
$45,000 worth of $35,000 anniversary inventory, here's what
people don't understand.
Despite secondary prices being higher than retail, demand
isn't there.
Now the broke boy flippers are going to start undercutting
each other to secure gains.
Saw this happen when I was launching NFTs plus crypto
projects.
There's too much supply and people are trying to get out
fast.
What we can do is just buy underpaid 30th off other flippers
when we see the opportunity.
If we control the entire supply,
plan to load up another 50k in inventory this week.
Christmas is coming, and parents will want to buy for the
kids.
We just have to limit the supplies ourselves.
Be smart.
Yeah, let's double down.
It's the crypto bros.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
It's not over.
Oh, look at this one.
Oh,
Bye bye bye but here's more guys I've been flipping for the
last 10 years and can tell you this is the end of Pokemon
when Nike started releasing too many Jordans everyone
stopped wearing them during COVID when Walmart started
selling too many inflato pools everyone stopped going there
when Rayden Potter became overpriced all the white women
stopped buying overprinting is the sign of a failing
business and pokemon is on its last legs as for me i'm going
to try and return all this inventory it's useless and no one
is buying plans on shifting to reselling power tools are
next extremely untapped market and builders have infinite
money
I get enough flipping power tools.
They'll flip anything.
They'll flip anything with that.
What is this?
Mantle gymnastics.
I guess.
Thank you.
Do you have the secondary distributors selling at fair price
over cheap MSRP screenshot?
That one is great.
I don't know.
There's a lot of them this is gonna it's gonna start flip
bro we're gonna we're gonna go back we're gonna go back in
the loop we're gonna start flipping toilet paper again it's
not gonna stop maybe we're gonna go all the way back to
toilet paper at this rate you know what I blame COVID it's
he has a I blame COVID for the flipping culture ever since
the toilet paper shit I blame it was all because of the
toilet paper man it's because of that that we went too far.
It was like the first stone.
Oh, one guy.
Thank you.
Super Chat.
Local crackheads.
I've been flipping power tools for decades already.
It's an over tab market.
Builders here who can confirm.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Not first.
The Super Chat.
Thank you.
This gives me maximum shot at road.
with super chat thank you thank you um um adhesive thank you
super chat thank you thank you we flipping the waltz boys
thank you but super chat thank you thank you patra sue thank
you with super chat thank you builders do not buy their own
tools each employee in a trade is responsible for their own
tools mr electric send them to the cash cleaner and have
them disappear thank you super chat thank you thank you tj
thank you but super chat thank you thank you hey dokey is my
girlfriend She's in chat here somewhere and it's our
anniversary.
You can say congrats.
Congratulations and congrats on your anniversary guys I'm so
proud of you that who introduced Doki bird first to each
other.
Who was it?
Also, I remembered it was somebody's birthday But then we
got trapped into the loop realm Brian, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
They can wrap their tears with the Pokemon packs that you
was super chat Thank you thing.
All right, so apparently before I so unfortunately someone
Someone said it was their birthday.
And then we got, it was a little too late.
We were already in the looping, we were trapped in the loop
realm.
So let me find out whose birthday it was.
Let me, it's, all right.
Whose birthday was, who was the lucky, okay, unlucky little
guy because we were stuck there for a while.
They're like, surely, surely she'll get out of the loop.
So I, surely she'll get out of the loop.
any moment right oh jr gomez thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you it's my birthday my birthday ish wishes
one more loop please oh my god happy birthday gomez thank
you the super chat thank you thank you happy birthday to you
happy birthday to
birthday to you happy birthday oh my god i'm just choking on
my soul happy birthday oh my god i found like It sounded
like a Murlock.
I sounded like a Murlock there.
Oh my God.
I was a Murlock for a second.
You good?
No, I'm not good.
I...
It's my Murlock impression.
Was that not good?
I'm drowning.
I'm drowning right now.
Sorry.
I should not have like hydrated before I transition back to
this.
screen oh my I was I was drinking water and the water was
not fully down my throat yet yeah I'm sorry my bad my bad
should not I should have hydrated a little earlier quail
think of a super chat thinking thank you how I do that I
literally was drinking water and I had didn't I didn't
swallow all the water So there was like water residue.
And I was like, ah, so see, I can't do that anymore because
there's no more water in my throat.
Wait, let me hydrate.
I can do it again.
Wait.
Ah, ah.
Oh, yeah.
That's all it takes.
Wow.
I got it Well, thank you It's like, it's that croaky
drowning Thank you, thank you, thank you Thank you, dokey
for the extra loop That he said, thank you, super chat Thank
you, dad's like, I'll save you I'll save you Hey, no No
Anyway, the loops brother Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Now let's actually play the game, guys.
I don't know.
All right.
So I don't know if sound, we have sound people.
We're going to have sound people here today.
So we'll see.
Maybe we'll have mods to help with sound balancing because I
don't know if any sound people are online.
We have one sound guy that escaped the seller because they
managed to get out of the sound basement to Europe.
up to vexbo i was like how did you get out of there out hey
jake thank you super chat thank you thank you um merlock
stream when so one of the sound guys broke out and is in the
uk right now so it's just gonna i don't know the other sound
guys still there it's still trapped i don't know if they
also escaped i was like how did you get out who let you out
all right let's see all right cat cash cleaner simulator all
right let's see jock the cat the fuck is that all right what
are the what are some of the uh we'll have
oh this oh i like the music for this music for this is uh
Bada, bada, bada.
Music for this is pretty fire.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, hold.
I like...
Uh...
What do you hold?
I'm a hold sprint person.
Bada, bada, bada.
Alright, let's play.
Yeah, the music is good.
It's pretty banging right now.
It's a banger.
Alright, how's the sound right now?
It did.
Actually, not gonna lie.
Yeah, it did give Friday Night Funkin' vibes.
Wow!
Okay.
There is obviously motion blur, but yeah, I couldn't turn
down.
Well, I don't like that there was obviously motion blur, and
I couldn't turn down the motion blur.
Oh, there it is.
Never mind.
Oh, shit.
It was just okay.
All right.
Never mind.
I can turn down the motion blur.
Thank God.
All right.
It's problem solved.
Um, yeah, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Fest, getting drunk, can't stay straight, but I'm here for
the stream.
Yay!
We're having fun at October Fest.
Okay, I'll go take a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything else?
Alright, oh, that feels a lot better.
Alright, I don't know how people can function.
Like, I know I keep saying that, but I legitimately don't
know how people can function with motion blur.
Alright, I think that's fine.
God, it's such high sensitivity.
All right, let's turn it down even a bit more.
I'm not a huge fan of the sensitive.
Whoa All right, maybe 10 All right, there we go Actually,
I'm sorry.
I'm super anal about this because it's like it's like barely
a bar of 15 All right All right, you can take the new quest
in the dark and shine dark net app How's the head you had
quite the day yesterday, huh?
That's me.
Mom?
I did?
I'll teach you everything.
Whoa!
Thanks, Mom?
Okay.
Am I still choppy?
Let's see.
I mean, could turn down.
Turn it down.
I feel like we don't really need 120.
I just did it just for...
JK.
Mother?
What's this?
Okay, notes.
Collect bills in the money stack, then buy in it with a
strap to create a money pack.
Combine multiple money packs and wrap them in a cling
plastic wrap to create a money block.
Oh, that can't.
That's not too bad.
Oh, my God.
That's too much.
Too much information.
Too much.
Mom, help.
Mom, mommy.
We need help.
What?
Okay, collect it all.
And then...
Tape it.
Store.
Oh.
How do I...
Bam.
Alright, I did it.
Mother, I did it, mommy.
There we go.
I did it Oh my god Is mommy Proud of me Oh Approach it and
then Is that not good?
Is that not good enough?
But I I put money in bad Aww I'm multiple That whole effin
Okay Throw an item Okay Nice.
You need to take out your smartphone.
Oh, wait.
Let me drop this first.
There you go.
Hey, Mr. Fresh.
It's me again.
Check your phone.
I sent you a message.
Okay.
Uh.
Do you like your new phone?
It's like a little baby monitor.
Did you find...
Not yet, but I will.
Wonderful.
I'm going to be your first client.
All you need to do is send me the money.
Can you do that for me?
I'm confused mother can you please teach me my angel listen
mommy has some cooking to do Bible you're cooking for who is
it for my new daddy our guests of course but don't worry
I'll save some for you guess what do you mean hello mother
mama oh don't worry she's just in a guys guys she's like
she's just in a cave right now she's in a tunnel she's not
getting reception she's not ignoring me i am cubic get
prepared to deliver i think i can do that um place the money
pack wait for it to reach the convener okay oh the money
pack the first delivery okay um
okay oh i'm sorry mr oh cc i guess i got carried didn't
notice the to complete my yuking reputation the higher
reputation darknet the better your chance of getting a job
see guys see my mama wasn't ignoring me see guys i
understand there you go goodbye goodbye money mama said if i
do a good job i get a little reward yay oh i got a new quest
from a dark web all right what does this say uh send at
least 150 bills of any in any box oh i get a gift box nice
or how's the sound so far oh my god what's in this box for
me i got you so bad at this i got tape yippee how did she
know i've always wanted tape wow Dave
and Christmas all together is this oh my god and it's more
Dave let's go
oh wait wait that's like okay Merry Christmas Wow how did
she know that's everything a boy wanted Dave how did she
know Oh my god, I bet I know what's in here!
And deep!
More deep!
How did she know?
Oh, I wonder what...
Oh, wait, these are all the hard times to start rapping.
I can't...
I just wrapped the 10s?
Or does it matter?
What currency?
Wait, task tracker.
All right.
Oh, the tape you can eat.
Send at least, oh, at least 150.
Oh, if any.
Okay, I'll set that.
Okay, it's any.
So, 10.
And then tape.
And then I put that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's tape in here.
I shouldn't be in here.
It should only be the cash.
All right.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
I'm doing a good job.
So it doesn't matter.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
That's not 10.
Wait, can I do more than 10?
Does it matter?
And just keep piling it?
Wait.
Wait, it doesn't matter.
And just keep...
And you can just keep holding this forever.
like up to 10.
Where does it stop?
Alright, I'm at 63 now.
Why is some badass stacks?
Okay.
Everything...
Does it stop at 82?
Does it stop at 100?
Well, we're about to find out.
Oh, it stops at 100.
Oh, I can just tape it up to 100.
a lot easier.
Wait a minute.
Why the fuck was I doing it by 10?
Okay, we gotta stop at 40, though, because I already have 10
and 100 taped up.
Alright, now we know.
Oh, shit.
Uh...
Oh, I lost.
Oh, that's not good.
That's 42.
Uh...
Oh, wait a minute.
in it.
Oh, um, okay, we gotta recount this.
All right, we're gonna recount it.
It's dirty.
I don't know, for some reason I thought my hands would just
stop by itself.
All right.
Boop.
All right, Mommy.
I got it.
Very goodbye, money.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, money.
Hope you have a safe trip.
Kuka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can see Doki cashing out all her super chats and literally
just living in a room covering cash.
Why put it in bank?
Exactly.
Might as well, like, stuff your pillows with cash.
It's like your sleeping dreaming of money.
Hug?
What's the point of money if you don't spend it?
That's it.
We're going shopping.
Mommy is taking me shopping.
Yippee!
You're taking me out of here?
Really?
You silly goose.
Huh?
What?
We do all are shopping online.
Oh, you're so right.
I'll hurt myself if I go outside.
You're so right, mummers.
So, what do I spend my money on?
She's right, guys.
She's so right.
She doesn't want me to hurt myself.
She's trying to keep me safe, guys.
I don't need to go out.
I have everything I want here.
Your money?
No, darling.
Didn't your mom ever tell you you don't own anything here?
I can't remember my mom.
But you're my real mom, though.
Wow, that must have hit you pretty much.
pretty hard you probably don't remember your real name well
it doesn't matter yay I'm your mom now so I'll tell you you
don't own anything here and don't even think about stuff in
your pockets or stashing anything away down there we'll find
you if you do but another of that time to shop till you drop
alright you're so right mummers you know what's best for me
let's do it alright place bag on a pallet there's a bag is
this a bag no that's a pillow mommy didn't teach me what a
bag is oh look mommy got me a toy knife if that's a toy on a
pallet there's a pallet um this
what's in it that's nothing all right there you go open to a
black market all right time to shop time to shop till i drop
oh yeah i know i asked earlier about what you think about
the sound uh but guys now i'm looking at chat what do you
guys think about the sound is the sound good now oh mr fresh
i've heard good things about you we'll see how you handle a
small favor and see how it goes from here i'm not conspiracy
theorist i just prefer to do my own research trust but
verify you understand you must also understand that who
controls money controls the world do me a favor and i'll
remember you when i'm in charge uh-huh let me get to work
till y'all know my mama's in charge here this game is too
unrealistic jokie's giving loads of money instead of
hoarding it like scrooge mcduck lali take you with a super
chat thank you thank you oh i get a money counter mommy said
i can buy anything i want
Then money.
Alright, let's see.
How much money do I even have?
Oh, $1,000.
Okay, I don't think I need a barrel or anything.
Money tape, cling wrap.
Carp, do I have these unlocked?
Oh, I don't.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't have that unlocked.
I only have one thing unlocked.
It's the money counter, apparently.
Alright.
In 16 minutes, what am I going to do?
Wait for your order to be delivered?
And I have Uber priority.
I guess not.
I do have other quests, though.
I can buy multiple and wrap them in cling plastic wrap.
Create a money block.
And any wet bound with a wrapped in plastic box.
I don't have a suitcase, but I'll take it.
Look it.
Is there another one?
Just that?
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Well, I got my own suitcase now.
Alright.
And then...
Oh.
That's a lot of money.
money whoa it's all this money is so dirty i gotta fix this
wait how do i do this the golden baby is in this i know how
to count money make money stacks and help you start bills oh
okay no oh wait what do i
I'll just keep putting it in my hand I guess Down with strap
with strap in pack I'll just keep holding it
I tape it, and then I surround clean plastic.
Is this a money block?
Did I do it?
How do I...
Oh, I'm really bad with this.
Guys, I might be really bad at this.
I'm money laundering.
Alright.
Um...
Okay, and then...
And then I do this and I...
Oh.
Um...
Uh...
Oh!
Um...
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
Mommy, help.
Mommy,
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Uh.
And then I just keep pressing that.
I'm learning!
Oh, I'm gonna make mummers so proud of me.
You're gonna be so...
Oh, look at this!
I wrap, and then...
I put it in here.
And then I keep going.
that and and then i put it in the cling wrap and then i make
a giant money block and then there you go tape i think we're
all happy you know that doki won't be kidnapped they force
their work for the cartel you just need to watch you
struggling i'm doing my best what are you talking about i
think i'm doing very well Thank you for the super chat,
Kuga.
I think I am a model employee.
Employee of the month right now.
I'm trying.
That's all that matters.
I'm making the effort.
Alright.
There you go.
And then next up.
And is there any more?
Why, there's one more here.
It is so convenient.
Wait, Monday night?
This honoring is so easy, why don't people do this more
often?
Wait a minute, this is, this is pretty easy.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Got that.
And then, okay, we're gonna bound all of these wet money
into a little...
Alright.
Like, that is...
Wait, that doesn't even tell me.
How much money?
How much money is that?
How am I supposed to know?
I never counted any of the...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Whoops.
Alright.
Oh, this is... Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait, I can fix this.
Um, oh, where was this supposed to be?
Oh, I don't want to hope my mommy doesn't find out that I
made a mess.
All right.
All right, there you go.
How do I know how much money I have?
I don't know.
Wait, where's my, where's my money's oh my gosh well okay um
um i don't know if that's 45 000 i don't know i didn't pay
attention oh um this should be 45 i think this is all this
has to be 45.
wait what
all right this has to be right oh we're gonna figure out
this is 45k that should be 45k by my calculations that's 45k
you can use the start point check that off don't all right
let's check the totals um
Is that a 40...
How do I use my smartphone to check?
Uh...
That was close.
How do I...
What?
Phone scanner?
Why can't I scan?
Why not?
Oh, my money!
Wait, where is it?
I can't scan.
I don't have it unlocked yet.
uh well and i find myself in you before you you boxes of wet
money or the actors on our scene you must show them their
marks are you serious what money speaks in so to voice you
see is almost imperceptible even to the most observant
audience pay attention inside the box their bills or inside
a suitcase an empty stage waiting for its actor to take
their marks position and perfection that's all i ask once
your work is complete i will you deliver the suitcase hinges
on your performance why you go through all this trouble
because there's no mere charade my boy it's neither now
break a leg how how how do I know this is 10k this 45k oh um
mummers we need help oh oh okay Uh, maybe there's like, oh,
uh, oh, there's so many things I can buy.
Mommy did not check that baby needs ADHD medication.
Things are flying around the room.
Thank you, Blue Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, Mommy.
Oh, what do I do?
How do I know it's 45k?
That's so much, buddy.
Um.
Oh.
It'll be fine.
I think that's 45k.
Much more money value.
Nothing else.
No mark.
Yeah.
Don't fake money.
I did so well.
Yippee.
I told you.
It all worked out in the end.
It's 50 shades of cash.
I load out 10,000 in a black sport bag in a hundred dollar
bill.
Alright, that seems easy enough.
Whoa!
Is this a hundred?
Okay, only a hundred.
Alright, we're doing it.
Okay, let's grab this here and then get our...
Wait, I'm doing it!
Wait, I'm doing so well!
We're doing so well, guys.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, there's more money.
Alright.
Boop.
Keep going.
Alright, then we wrap this up.
And that is a hundred, hundred dollar bills.
That's like...
10k?
That's...
That's 10k.
10k that's oh that's 10k that's 10k yeah yeah yeah so and
the black sport bag we don't have a black sport bag though i
did not provide me a black sport bag i have to buy my own
black sport bag um black sport bag what does a black sport
bag even look like i just have a backpack supplies is it in
supplies cardboard I just have a backpack but my next one is
that black black sport bag are you a black sport bag you are
you are okay all right wait I might need to wrap it though
I'll wrap it I'll cover it up nice and clean guys it's been
this bean counter flip the table should mommy collar shirts
or get a replay i'm doing mommy's proud of me all right
whoop there we go can i change the radio all right i only
one channel mommy only gave me one channel 9 900 okay well i
need one one hundred dollar bill.
I... What do you mean?
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
I don't... Oops.
But it says 10.
Oh, man.
Oh, geez.
What do I do?
Oh.
Do I have a black bag that I can buy.
Oh, where's Mama?
Oh, where is she?
I need help.
I need another black sport bag.
A suitcase.
Traveling.
I don't have another black bag.
Oh, classic sport bag.
Okay.
Okay, we'll have a classic all right don't worry everything
will be fine okay if we're gonna wait here might as well
take another order because like it's gonna be a while till
it shows up uh in a backpack bound with straps the packs of
any oh any okay i can do that any pack i can do work with
any i can work with any
Oh, that's cute.
It's like a little bonus for me.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I don't...
Why is there no counter?
How much money is that?
Oh, I should have counted.
Why didn't I count?
This is black.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, mommy, I'm...
Oh, wait.
Was that a hundred?
the hundred okay all right okay all right here we go um hope
all right we got it i assume this might be 10 i'm just gonna
i'll just go the extra mile this should be 10k i think i
think this is 10k i i oh i think so this looks like about
10k all right all right this this this looks like about 10k
we're gonna see you right now i think we're good i i think
yay i knew it i knew this was about 10k i
I'm so good at this game, guys.
Alright.
I bet Mama is proud.
It's 10k.
10 dry money bound with strap of packs of any in a dry box.
I can do that.
Whoa, that's a lot.
wait is this wet
that's not good
oh oh whoops
oh oh nothing the way
worry about.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh dear.
I can only imagine a spell down there.
Mr. Barash Bacon.
Looks like those piles of wet cash saved you from death.
And I bet that money is all dry now.
What a lucky boy.
Next time you won't be so lucky.
Next time mommy will finish the job.
Mommy's just having a bad day.
guys she loves me see see look at that i'll be back soon
she's just she's just had a bad day guys she doesn't need
all of that she loves me oh i have that's five thousand
dollars okay oh that's 10k wait i got 10k I need to put it
in a box.
Okay, box.
And then, wait, let me...
Alright.
And I got burned in the backpacks.
Is this one?
Which backpack was it?
There were so many backpacks.
Holy shit.
Okay, I guess this backpack.
Uh...
Do I throw again?
I don't remember.
Oh, throw.
There we go.
If mommy wants me to burn that backpack, I will burn the
backpack.
Alright, where's the other backpack?
There we go.
And then...
Wait, where's the last backpack?
I don't know where I put the last one.
Wait, was that the backpack with the money?
wait was that I'm gonna admit it did I did I burn the
backpack with the money did I oh no this
is surely this was oh thank God okay wait is this the Oh,
no.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Mommy doesn't know.
I... Mommy doesn't know.
I can't...
Oh, you won't know, right?
Oh, no.
No, no.
Oh no, I put in a box.
Oh, there it is.
There's the- okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, this is- This is okay.
It's okay.
I put it in the box.
I put it in a box.
Alright.
Okay, everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
We did it.
It was in the box.
Off you go.
Goodbye.
Cursed is avoided.
Yeah.
thank god nothing to worry about whoa wait what's this
nice you got or just don't hesitate toss in the dry oh it's
the dryer okay do i have wet money i don't know i don't
think i do yeah my reputation's going up
i have to pan pick these bullets myself Gosh, what a waste
of ammo.
We can recycle this.
Alright, because burning trash is always a good idea.
Burning?
I think it's burning.
Burning ammo casing is always a good idea.
It's always a good idea to do.
okay all right dark net tab
uh send and legit use a uv lamp oh that's a lot of work i'm
already not doing so well okay any dollar bills oh i can do
that all right any dollar bills in a sport bag is this a
sport no that's not sport fat all right here we go
okay oh wait how much money is that
okay 5,040 okay this is 5,040 um
Do you think I'm doing a good job?
Do you think I'm good at money laundering, guys?
Okay, this is 4,000.
5,000!
No!
Okay.
5,000.
5, 10.
15.
I think that's 15.
Alright.
They're doing fine.
Okay, and then I go buy a sport bag.
Alright.
Sport bag.
Where is a sport bag?
Money counter, shopping cart, washing machine.
Okay, sport bag.
I was near sport bag.
We have our 15k right here um and then i think i can take
another order while we wait uh what's this load out clean
and not ink stain in any dollar oh oh please where's mommy
oh there's so many things oh okay um Not ink stain in any
da- Okay.
Alright.
How do I know?
How?
Oh, it's lag.
Oh, this is lag, too!
Ah!
Oh.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, this is...
Oh.
Oh, you.
Oh, no.
My mom, that's what the knife is for.
Where's the knife?
Where did I put it?
How do I move this?
Oh, God.
Oh, where do I put this?
Is this here?
Oh, where's this?
the where did i put the knife i thought it was just a little
toy that mommy got me
wait where's the knife
okay all right i'm okay okay okay now that i can i'm working
i didn't know i was working the entire time where the fuck
is the knife Oh, where is it?
Oh!
Mommy, I flashbanged myself.
What do I do?
Oh!
Where is anything?
Oh, my system is everywhere.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
And then... chop.
Chop.
Okay, and then...
Oh.
There we go.
Now it's fine.
Okay, 15k.
But...
Okay, 100.
4,800.
No!
Okay.
So he's keeping her workplace as organized as her IRL.
Okay, 5, 10.
Thank you, Super Chatkoos.
Thank you, thank you.
And 15!
I did it!
It's not that hard.
Alright, now I whopped this up.
And...
Alright, that's 15k.
Let's put this in the sport bag first.
Um...
And then...
We'll put that...
Oh, that's a lot more extra money than it should be.
There you go.
Alright, another job well done.
Another job well done.
They're gonna be so proud of me.
I'm so good at money laundering.
Nice!
Exact money calculations!
Look at that!
Alright, um...
What?
Okay.
15.
Alright, that's 15.
15 and then um wait what is this oh what is this oh no what
value are these what are your value it's okay we don't need
a no all right four thousand eight hundred oh shit no wait
wait um three thousand three thousand three thousand three
thousand uh oh three six nine seven eight nine ten eleven k
uh
where's my knife
okay all right oh i lost track three six nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen thirteen 14k, 14k, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20,
21, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25.
This is 25, and then 25 plus 15, um, 37, okay, and that's
37k.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, do I not have any more cellophane wrap?
Why do I need 37K?
Um, oh, oh, oh, okay.
all right 37 um 38 39 44 42 42 this should be 42 and you did
it okay 40 42 all right and then in a sport bag i have a
sport bag oh i hope she's my whole mama is proud of me right
now I think they counted correctly.
Don't worry.
That's $42,000.
There we go.
Yay!
No fake money.
Let's go!
We're so good!
That's $42k right there.
Oh, is this how I clean it?
Only possible use it while holding money yet two days mark
with a special iron maintenance oh okay so that's how i
clean what happened to the dirty money all right okay all
right um am i um oh oh that's how oh yeah no no it's okay no
it's okay it's oh that's no it's okay oh we have a washing
machine okay um okay let's see all right now they have a
washing machine hurry oh okay all right um Is it cleaning?
Stop it!
Where are you?
Why aren't you clean?
Maybe you gotta be hard?
Uh-huh.
That's it.
Are you...
is it is this so blue oh yeah okay oh this is not the right
oh it's not you don't clean it was oh Oh
Don't know now they went down their world Okay
Okay, all right there you go there you go Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait Wait, wait, I think it's clean now.
I think it just needed to be dry.
I think I... Okay, alright, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright.
No, no, see, it's dry.
It's dry now.
Alright, let's see.
5... 15k.
i got this all right five thousand five ten thousand ten
thousand and then uh okay well oh no okay it's fine oh fuck
okay um surely this will make 15 okay oh stop stop stop no
okay okay in there alright okay 3,000 okay which one is oh
Oh no, I don't know, I've lost count.
I don't know which one is...
Okay, okay.
One of these is 5K.
Okay, I...
assume is this these are 50s so it has to be these two it
can't be anything else right and then 3000
okay wait no
okay all right i think i'm doing it and then we'll try to
make sure it's off 50s and wait i think i figured it out i
guys i think i i think i figured it out the slides are all
50s okay and then
i'll put that in
oh no where's
um okay okay here we go
we're almost there oh we're almost there I just need I just
need two more all right there we go we did it all right that
should be 15k and then sport bag oh where did I put it okay
Alright, come on.
Oh, is there something in there already?
Alright.
Here we go.
See, guys, nothing to worry about.
I figured it out.
See?
There's nothing to worry about.
Everything is okay.
Everything is okay up here, up in the dokey brain.
Exact money value, single, nothing else.
No fake money.
Perfect packs!
Let's go!
That's a fucking go.
Oh my god, everything's under control.
That's right.
Now I'm five star on Uber money laundering.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just curious, Doki, is this what laundry night is like for
you?
Just trying to figure out what things you own, which
settings to use.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If it works, it works, chat.
If it works, it works.
You know what?
I'm so proud of myself.
I'm gonna do something hard.
That's right.
Send in the UV lamp.
Oh no.
Why did I do that?
Oh no, Doki, you might have went too far.
Oh no.
Why did you do that, Doki?
What are you gonna do now?
You already?
You flew him too close to the sun?
What are you gonna do?
Wait.
No, fuck, okay.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, these are legit, right?
This should be legit.
Oh, wait.
This is the power.
cash up plus 50 dollars what i'm so stupid no okay okay it's
fine it's fine it's fine we'll just put this here and 2,100
surely we can
2,300 oh no where's my oh where's my uv lamp.
Oh.
Anything in here?
Wait, there's extra money in here.
How much money is in here?
Why can't I tell?
Uh, get some ice cream of Doki's brain after all this work.
She is forced to do a duck that gives a super chat.
Where's my UV lamp?
How am I supposed to know?
Oh, it's almost here.
Okay.
It's here all right let's see how all right how do you do
this okay counterfeit bills nothing you know find dark place
and let what
is this what
is the bad cash
oh oh no
oh oh oh
sorry sorry sorry I crashed out a little bit I I I don't
think mommy's gonna be happy about me I I don't I I don't I
think mommy's gonna be happy.
No.
Um.
Okay.
One.
Oh.
Two.
There's three...
Four...
Oh!
What is the fight?
There has to be a better efficient way!
There has to be a better way oh no don't do this no are you
okay okay okay my other ass there it can't this can't be it
this can't be it no no this can't be It has to be an
easier...
It has to be easy...
It has to be an easier way!
They can't do this to me!
Oh...
Oh my god.
I can't!
I've only got ten times!
Oh, this is only ten!
There's no...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Why does it...
Why is money lying so hard?
Oh.
okay okay okay i got this okay these are legit i know for
sure these are legit all right this is legit
oh my god oh i'm just surely all of this is Clean box surely
maybe maybe maybe this is 7k I want to move to the feet.
I think this is 7k
Goodbye I think that's 7k Yeah Yeah I did it I think you
should be doing some weird what cat energy only thank you
was a saber chat thank you thank you light uh let's see
we're figuring out you when you're busted and glad does it
hurt too much look yeah i did it i i told you i told you it
was that easy
okay all right and any dollar bills clean money in a medium
box and any dollar wait i'm i'm five star oh wait six stars
not six stars all right this one is easy oh it came in a
little teddy bear so cute so cute that's so cute find the
handle from the broken switch what oh my god what do you
mean there's some broken in what oh oh oh oh oh okay to get
the hold there's a ladder why do I have a ladder what's this
ladder doing here hello where do I bring this ladder to
mommy Why is there a ladder?
Where's the ladder come from?
I don't know anymore guys.
No, no, no.
Is that a handle?
No.
Oh, that's a box.
Why is there a handle?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh.
Maybe.
Maybe the sun's out.
Okay, the handle is red.
Oh, no.
No, is that...
That's a pencil.
That's a bullet.
Oh, no.
I can't, I can't anymore, but I'm strong enough.
I can't stop for me.
I'm not meant to do any of this.
I'm not...
I'm having to do this!
Yeah, take me out!
It's not, it's not my path!
It's not my career path!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
You got this, you got this, you got...
Oh, if you got this, it's nothing to worry.
of balance now you've done this before you've done this
you've done all you you've done this before you all right
all right 15k 15k okay um okay surely all of this is gonna
be 15k right
oh for it for the
No.
You're not glad you're having fun and continue to have a lot
more.
I'm not reaching.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm having so much fun.
Corridor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mommy's gonna be very disappointed in you, Duki.
Oh.
No.
Guys.
Ah.
Maybe if I jump, I'll break my leg.
Maybe.
I'll take my own way out.
My own way.
Don't do it, noki.
Don't do it.
No.
Oh my God, so give me up.
Oh my God, yes, yes.
Yes, I can.
I can.
I can't.
I thought this game would, I, I can't, I can't, I can't.
I can't, I can't!
I can't anymore!
I can't, I can't, I can't.
I can't do this.
I can't, my guys, I can't!
I cannot do this anymore!
I'm like, Ben Kesheirgud must be crying so much right now.
Colton, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I
can't, I can't, I can't,
I don't, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no
okay okay i can do this i can do this okay in a large box
this is a large box this is this is uh okay this is 4 600
which is almost like 15k it's it's almost 15k it's the best
part it's almost 15k It's almost 15k.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Stop.
Alright.
Any amount.
I don't care.
Any amount of money is flat.
Okay.
That is...
Oh my god.
Who is this again?
That's 4k.
And then this is... Oh, what is this again?
Oh, I just... I don't... I don't remember.
I don't... Oh, I don't remember.
I don't remember I I don't remember okay one two three four
five six seven this should be 15k here you go is that is
this not a large box what would be a large box what is a
what is a large is this a medium a small box is this a small
box is this I don't gosh all right why is it beeping is this
not a large box of which they told me to put it in is there
a box that's bigger than this okay cardboard X XL all right
where is just regular okay regular box all right
help okay okay okay okay that's fine that's fine we have
almost 15k in here that that looks you know what just to be
sure let me put there you go surely this has to be 15k this
has to be 15k there's a stack of cash eventually it makes
15k this is this is 15k this is a stack of cash that should
be 15k That should be 15k right there.
That's...
Alright, alright.
Order.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Mommy's gonna be so proud of me.
He's gonna be so happy that I got...
I got it.
I...
I did it.
That's 15.
That's 15k.
Okay.
okay okay that's 13k 13k and then uh you know what i'll give
you an extra file you know oh that's fine that's fine that's
okay okay all right okay and then that's fine we have we
have 15k when i study abroad and certain three were hired to
pay in cash it took us in a room a machine like that piles
of cash lying around a man with cigar to make the payment.
Why am I giving you PTSD right now?
Karama, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There you go.
We just need to put this in a large box and then we're free.
And then we're free.
This is the, this, we're free after this is it.
This is the last one.
This is the, and then I'll break out.
I don't care what mommy says.
I can't, I can't do this anymore.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
I can't, I can't.
All right, big box.
Here you go.
Okay, my last one.
All right.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
I can't.
I don't.
Why is there so much more to us?
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I
can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't,
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't